hey ihr lieben wir machen heute was
total leckeres denn ich bin nachher
eingeladen bei meinen schwiegereltern
und ich möchte nicht mit leeren händen
gehen ist ja klar
man sollte nicht mit werden hinten gehen
und wir machen deswegen einen schönen
mandarinen blechkuchen der total der
kreis besteht aus einer website schicht
quark käse kuchen masse und natürlich
mandarin als topping habe ich mir
überlegt handeln aber das könnte
natürlich auch noch selbst entscheiden
wir machen jetzt zuallererst grundkurs
nämlich den mürbeteig wir benötigen mail
außerdem butter die habe ich in kleine
stücke geschnitten weißen und braunen
zucker und 1 1 als erstes krempeln wir
uns sitzt die ärmel hoch und verkneten
die vier bzw fünf zutaten zu einem teig
ich habe ja den zucker ausgetauscht ich
habe die hälfte mit weißen und die
andere richtung braun zugenommen finde
das sieht man dann im teig und es
schmeckt man auch und ich mache das
jetzt hier gemacht mit den händen
natürlich könnt ihr auch eine
küchenmaschine nehmen ist aber in meinen
augen gar nicht notwendig
[Musik]
nach drei bis vier minuten merkt ihr
dass der teig richtig schön festwirt und
ihr habt so ein tag an einem stück und
den geben wir jetzt auf unser backblech
ich habe da jetzt aber noch ein bug
haben drumherum gemacht haben wir
einfach einen schönen geraden abschluss
an den seiten und auf dem boden habe ich
noch einen backpapier gegeben und die
mittag gibt einfach schön glatter
darüber geben so der mürbeteig ist
fertig in meiner backform ich werde euch
die mars auf jeden fall unten in der
infobox schreiben
und jetzt machen wir weiter mit der
füllung dafür zeige ich euch hier einmal
zutaten so wir benötigen magerquark
außerdem doppel raum frischkäse zucker
und chris hier habe ich eine bio orangen
mandarinen aus der dose gestiftete
mandeln und wer mag noch ein bisschen
kokos so meinen magerquark habe ich hier
schon in einer großen schüssel gebe ich
den frischkäse noch mit dazu und im
prinzip werden alle zutaten miteinander
verrührt die reihenfolge ist auch egal
sagt euch jetzt nur wie ich dabei
vorgehen
das gebe ich noch den zucker dazu und
außerdem in kriegs und beim kreis es ist
egal ob ihr hart war hartweizen oder
weich weit sind die kleinen versprecher
gehabt und jetzt war ruhig das erst
aneinander
jetzt habe ich das ganz gut miteinander
verrührt sogar zu ein paar sekunden und
jetzt gebe ich die eier dazu
das lockert die masse so ein bisschen
auf ach ich gebe einfach alle auf einmal
dazu sct alles miteinander verrührt so
die eier haben sich gut mit der masse
verbunden ist schon mal sehr gut aus und
jetzt kommt noch der orangen schein
aktiv dazu findet das gibt noch mal so
ein bisschen fruchtigkeit ihr könnt
jetzt auch vanille nähen oder
zitronenschale aber orange passt richtig
fit zu den mandarinen
[Musik]
als nächstes geben jetzt die hälfte der
mandarine rein und zwar möchte ich das
jetzt erstmal in der krim drin haben
damit die durch das durchaus ein
bisschen zerfleddert werden
hört sich brutal an ist es aber gar
nicht und die andere hälfte geht dann
auf den kuchen drauf
unsere füllung ist fertigten auch
superschnell gehabt selber gesehen und
jetzt gehen wir das ganz einfach auf den
mürbeteig und verstreichen das blatt und
jetzt kommen unsere toppings ich habe ja
noch die übrig gebliebenen mandarinen
die gibt jetzt einfach oben drauf und
dann die mandeln und ich was im laufe
des videos sind ehrlich bin bin mir
sicher mit kokos schmeckt auch richtig
lecker also mandeln und kokos
und ihr könnt jetzt auch so ein bisschen
in den teig reindrücken gibt es auch
dafür aus
[Musik]
also dieser blechkuchen der schreibt so
richtig nach frühling der schreit so
raus frühling komm endlich ich bin
bereit mir richtig richtig lecker ich
bin super gespannt wenn er gleich aus
dem ofen kommt den ofen hab ich übrigens
vorgeheizt auf 180 grad ober und
unterhitze und dann sage ich euch gleich
die backzeit ich jesus von 35 bis 40
minuten aus sagt euch dann aber wie
lange es bei mir gedauert hat so ihr
lieben genau wie's voraus bestimmt habt
35 minuten hat das ganze gedauert dann
habe ich anschließend noch einen tipp
stündchen auskühlen lassen und jetzt ist
unser mandarin cheesecake mitwirkt boden
in und fertig auskühlen lassen hat und
ganz wichtig auf fast im mist und
auskühlen lassen weil sonst die masse
einfach zu weit und ich habe jetzt hier
noch mein einteiler und ich mache heute
so kleine häppchen den ex apple manager
man gleich noch was anderes leckeres
nämlich kinderfilm türkische spezialität
aber auch hier das rezept haben wir auch
das völlig unten in der infobox
ja ja orientalisch auf jeden fall habe
ich das hier in 30 teile einfach hier
drauf drücken
dann kann man es ganz einfach
durchschneiden euro erhältlich genau ich
mache nur werbung
so und jetzt könnt ihr ihn einfach nur
noch servieren und genießen ich zeige
euch nochmal ganz kurze der aussieht vom
anschnitt so lecker so gut ihr müsst ihn
unbedingt nachmachen er schmeckt einfach
möchte schon länger hier riecht's auch
in der ganzen küche danach wirklich also
der ist total lecker überzeugt euch
einfach selbst die genauen mengenangaben
schreibe ich euch hier unten in die
infobox
ansonsten main kanal unbedingt
abonnieren wenn ihr das nicht schon
längst getan haben und sich über böse
mit euch und natürlich dem video ein
förmchen nach oben da lassen wenn es
euch gefallen hat und wir sehen uns aber
demnächst malchin und die glocke
aktivieren
genau wissen
[Musik]
ich wünsche euch ein wunderschönes
wochenende und dann auf der autobahn auf
dem weg nach köln
ich weiß nicht wo es hingeht das problem
ist der hamza wollten überraschung
machen
und ich habe keinen an also ich weiß
nicht woher ich solche sachen
zusammenpacken und mama hat mir noch
beim packen geholfen und meinte schon
sony das brauchst du nicht und das
brauchst du nun die weißrussin rechne
ich wollte gerne was unternehmen und
nicht überraschend sonst bin ich immer
so der mensch der alles raus findet also
wirklich interessant ich weiß irgendwann
schwitzen
wir sind hier am flughafen in köln
[Musik]
also ich hab nichts damit zu tun gehabt
kiki wurde überrascht wohin geht es auch
mal also ohne mich
also die waikiki was von gar nichts
dieser bericht wurde von mir